so next game against tol bot from
Brazil well he
probably wasn't that happy about football at the moment
Catalan main system yes knight E5
is an interesting move knight C6 is
now probably the best that I ca
n't do but I can't do it right there are
still some  Strange idea
Queen D6 that I'm trying out now. The
idea is to use this strange
queen maneuver to quickly bring the rook to D8
in order to then initiate counterplay against D4.
Dam and rook are opposite each other here.
I don't know exactly, but
since I have the other edge I
can't do that  maybe a really good
way, yes, shockingly, he
just takes my knight's
way
aha yes, I'm still quite a
buff, he just gives away his best piece, gives it away,
well, unfortunately Queen F3
can't play B6
[music]
and I'd like to have the bishop
Let's put it on the long diagonal.
Unfortunately, knight D7 doesn't work either
[music]
I'm not sure if I
have time for rook B8 and
so
I'll try it, it's a
bit
slow but the diagonal is just
too
tempting so
B6 knight C6  then bishop B7 yes yes well
you can do that if I take a bishop
I'll be in B4 so
with the
pawn principle um it
's now just a matter of whether I'll be
sitting on G2 mat at some point
so the question is how to do it in the
most clever way  I
could also play rook D5
and put everything on the d-line,
yes the knight has to go away from there,
actually Bishop D6 is coming, knight B5
I have to play a little faster,
even if the best moves don't always
come out,
maybe the white weakens itself
mercilessly here, let's see if  I
somehow find something how I
can punish this, so it could be that E4 now
gains material here, so the knight is out of here for now,
and now he lets me go to
C6 and then thinks he has knight A5,
but I can only
give check now  D with C6 I don't know if there's a
direct
threat of something, it looks dangerous but okay
he wants to buy himself out with the pawn I
don't know if I have something better,
well that's a sea pawn and the
bishop pair so he can attack that one,
well I can too  what to
attack
so now we have the bare endgame
with two bishops against knight and
bishop and one pawn more I have
a little less time that's not
so nice
but of course you can
carry it forward very nicely now
so the interesting question is which
pawn formation now  This is the right place,
but I also have to activate the bishops again.
Check it's
better not to put anything away given the short thinking time, it
can always happen easily.
Knights are weaker than bishops,
but they can
do forks. So, it's really easy to win
because it's all on one wing
is like that and the knight is now
somewhat
dominated
so time
was
[music]
[applause]
[music] yes,
I admit I don't have a very clear plan now, I would
n't like to exchange more
here,
yes I think I have to do E5 straight away,
nothing else will help  you
probably just can't get any
further
Check
so he can now
run a bit, the pawn
check that was clumsy of
him he doesn't have any
chess F1 Queen is
threatening so he really doesn't have any chess so
I can even
prepare Bishop H3 would have won too, yes it
was amazingly fast
But technically it wasn't entirely trivial, especially
with little time,
of course the zläf was simply
C6, but I didn't get more than extra pawns,
yes, although I absolutely don't understand how to
get the move, but
that's good